hi everybody i'm jonathan trance and
today i got another tactical challenge
for you so when you see the image on
your screen pause your video and we'll
see if you can solve it
so today same comes to us from the game
mckenas first Braunstein from 1965 sort
of a well known game so maybe some
people out there know about it but if
not go ahead pause your video at this
moment and see if you can find the
winning tactic for black so in this
position it may not appear at first
sight like there's any issues on the
back rank for white but actually black
here has a very spectacular move that
just wins on the spot and that move is
rook takes a three and remarkably even
though there's three different ways that
white can take the rook they all have
issues on the back rank for example if
you take with the Queen well now there's
a problem on the back rank so you check
and checkmate end of game you can't take
with the pawn of course because now that
hangs the rook and will lead to an
eventual checkmate if you take with the
rook in this position look takes a three
again we check on the back rank and mate
another funny interesting thing is well
you can hope maybe if I just play Queen
d1 or some other move that I can just
struggle down upon but again there's
issues on the back rank we can take and
give another check if you take you could
also make lift here and lose all your
pieces but otherwise it's again gonna be
a back rain checkmate
thank you everybody for watching please
let me know in the comments below were
you able to get this puzzle and hit like
share subscribe we'll see you next week
spread another technical challenge we
done dude